first of all I should inform you that
Chris didn't you date a woman who like
to urinate on you or something what was
that whole thing yeah she used to she
used to like to just piss on me she lik
to specifically piss in my belly button
um and I've had uh yeah I'm I'm I'm a
mixed bag thank you Ronnie I'm a mixed
bag um of stuff because you know a lot
of my girlfriends think I'm gay a lot of
times I'm not but a lot of i' I've you
know I was in why do they think that in
other words because you have trouble
getting it up or no no no the thing it's
up I think that you know I think that
I've had you know I've said you know I I
have I I I have sex with women but I
fall in love with men I think I like to
talk to a guy about World War II and
George Washington and that gets me nice
and stiff and then I'll go have sex with
a woman and just imagine it was the guy
so I it might be gay in my mind like I I
was engaged and then girl we called it
off because we we were hanging out you
know and for the first time she went
down on me we were dating and then she
slipped a tongue in the ass which
doesn't very happen very often slipped a
tongue in the ass and then two licks
bang bang I shot a load right off the
ceiling and and she starts looking at me
she's looking at me she's hysterical
crying I said why are you crying she
said this confirms you're gay and I was
like oh and called it all off really are
you serious that's a serious story w a
serious story she she really I told you
deep in my neighborhood these PE they
you know if you're not if you're not
working on cars if you're not a cop if
you haven't lost a limit of War you're
gay